okay so my first question is we started
off in much the same way between these
two questions right we start off here
for this question and we started off for
this question same premise we try to
work out the same thing on one solution
here and two solutions here they don't
explain why we have two solutions I just
try to work out how from the same
standpoint here but what I'm suggesting
it shouldn't that mean there would be
similar I'd like if I got one solution
here and speak to you one solution as
well because there so that is true and
the answer is actually something to do
with the denominator but the first we
started with what do we start with
right
this has to do it the first term doesn't
it right now what we define was the
second term but it not it used this
limiting something right you do have to
go back to the first term you actually
always have to use it right because it's
it's a on one - I'm not not tow - I'm on
this all right now in order to go back
to the first term from six you have to
introduce seats on our right so this is
no longer a constant like we had here
which we could just cancel out okay you
give me a fraction if you see why that's
the problem which is why right
as two over R minus R times one minus R
and 1/3 and 2/3 R one minus each other
there yeah the kind of like what you get
sort of things okay let me see if I can
unpack that a little more which is the
critical line because there's a line
where it goes from having one solution
or it looks like that's one solution and
then it clearly has two solutions
transition from here
okay now even at that point I think it's
still a bit unclear I could still have
had one solution right I think where it
really becomes clear it's actually from
here to here can you see why right
because this is what we introduced a
quadratic this is when it becomes a
quadratic and that's when we start to
factorize right in reality like it's all
the same equation okay so be talking
about which step is which is kind of
kind of a trivial but well this is what
we multiply by R now what are you
thinking about that all right you know
what I keep around if I gave you a
question like this how many solutions
are there there are two right and you
can automatically almost save it that's
cuz it's agree - yes now one of the
things we learn in like u89 is even
though you could divide through by x you
shouldn't do it right even though you
end up with a true statement why don't
we do it you lose a solution right
you'll emanate one right
going from degree 2 degree 1 you lose a
solution therefore we ought to expect
that at this step here when you go from
degree 1 to degree 2 don't worry the
degree 1 because you have the fraction
kind of degree 1 that's when it becomes
clear off can they read the auto
solution ok now what do we come up with
do they both work just wanna work in the
olive oil
they both work this is interesting right
you'll be careful you know we've looked
at lots of places where you solve a
quadratic but then you have to exclude
whether solutions come in all right so
where is a quadratic green here number
one there are two solutions but off the
uptick screw one okay but let's test
this out let's see what happens because
don't forget both of these are within
the domain restriction that we set
before namely this okay so it should
work right let's try the first one
oz equal to 1/3 I'm gonna get rid of
this because this is not the same now
what was the original question we try to
work out the first three terms right the
second term is always six so what should
the first term if the ratio is at third
right it's going to be to get from this
term to this x third rights I should
have 18 yes plus and so on but those are
the three out ones okay now what happens
let's let's test this out this should be
equal to this is the limiting son right
so it should be 18 that's the first time
I'm on one - sorry okay 18 divided by
2/3 that's gonna the 3/2 color on the
top 50 for divine there - sure enough it
worked okay let's just that the other
situation what if it was it's 2/3 the
second time is still six what's the
first term
nice it's mine because six is two thirds
of mine right next time is four okay sir
what's bubble sub meant to be equal to
wants a on what - ah okay which is nine
bond which is nine divided by 1/3
nine times three which is itself it does
work now just visually so what's
happening this series it starts bigger
doesn't it it's not closer to me but
it's faster doesn't it right because the
ratio here is smaller that's why by the
third term this is - this one is for
this one's that small about eight
streets more slowly so that's why they
end up at the same now you'll need to
watch out for this later on when you get
down to this point you're sorry for
generally the corners here okay
sometimes both will work sometimes only
one will work then you have to check it
out okay watch out for this domain it's
going to come back and bite you again
and again if you forget to look at it
but that's how pushing that mean kind of
plays out okay so if you get to that
plot see part Deepak in ya more
questions let me know
thank you